ABOUT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION, MAYBE EVEN STORMY
DANIELS.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED ABOUT HER
THIS MORNING.
LET'S GET AN OVERVIEW.
CHECK IN WITH CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
SCHEDULED TO START AT 6:00.
I AM TOLD IT WILL START A FEW
MINUTES LATE.
WE HAVE TIME TO SPEAK TO YOU.
THE BIG THING TO COME OUT OF
THIS, IT WAS INTENTIONALLY
ATTACHED TO IT IN THE NEWS THAT
BROKE LAST NIGHT THAT THE CIA
DIRECTOR MIKE POMPEO BACK ON
EASTER WEEKEND MADE A TRIP TO
PYONGYANG IN NORTH KOREA TO SIT
DOWN FOR PERSONAL TALKS WITH THE
NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG UN
TO TRY TO SET THE STAGE FOR AN
EXCEPTED SUMMIT BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG UN
THAT THE PRESIDENT SAYS COULD
HAPPEN SOMETIME IN LATE MAY OR
EARLY JUNE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TALKING
VERY OPTIMISTICALLY ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY FOR THAT SIT DOWN.
NOW WE LEARNED THE REASON WHY.
IT'S BECAUSE HE SAID THE MEETING
BETWEEN POMPEO AND KIM WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
THIS IN 20 SAID EARLIER TODAY.
>> HE JUST LEFT NORTH KOREA, HAD
A GREAT MEETING WITH
KIM JONG UN, AND GOT ALONG WITH
HIM REALLY WELL, REALLY GREAT.
HE HAS THAT KIND OF GUY.
REALLY SMART BUT HE GETS ALONG
WITH PEOPLE.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENTS HAD A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WAS FORMED
WITH NORTH KOREA.
YESTERDAY HE INDICATED THERE WAS
A MEASURE OF RESPECT NORTH KOREA
HAD FOR THE UNITED STATES.
QUESTIONS, WILL NORTH KOREA TAKE
CONFIDENCE BUILDING MEASURES
SUCH AS RELEASING THE THREE
DETAINED THERE AND WHAT WAS SAID
TO POMPEO DURING THE MEETING.
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS SO
OPTIMISTIC THAT NORTH KOREA IS
SERIOUS ABOUT DENUCLEARIZATION.
STILL WHEN I TELL YOU, A LOT OF
ISSUES, AS WE MENTIONED, COMING
IN.
TRADE, BIG ITEM ON THE AGENDA
TODAY AS WELL.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> PROBABLY THE THORNIEST ISSUE.
CLEARLY JAPAN IS WORRIED THAT
THEY WANT TO HAVE THEIR
INTERESTS REPRESENTED AT ANY
MEETING WITH KIM.
WHEN IT COMES TO TRADE, JAPAN
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
UNITED STATES BACK IN THE
TRANS-PACIFIC PARTNERSHIP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAYING LOOK,
WE HAVE BILATERAL TRADE DEALS
WITH SIX OF THE 11 NATIONS AND
WE THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A NEW
FREE-TRADE DEAL WITH CHINA, WITH
JAPAN, RATHER.
SHINZO ABE DOESN'T LIKE THAT
VERY MUCH.
HE IS RELUCTANT TO GET INTO A
FREE-TRADE AGREEMENT WITH THE
UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING WE HAVE
AN ENORMOUS TRADE DEFICIT WITH
JAPAN, AND HIS MANTRA ABOUT
TRADE AND NEW TRADE DEALS THAT
HE PLANS TO SPEND THIS YEAR
CRAFTING HAVE TO BE FREE, FAIR,
AND RECIPROCAL.
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> WE HAVE A MASSIVE DEFICIT
WITH JAPAN.
WE WILL, I BELIEVE AT THE END OF
A FAIRLY SHORT.
NEXT TIME, BE ABLE TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS.
I KNOW THEY ARE ORDERING LARGE
NUMBERS OF AIRPLANES, JET
FIGHTERS AND PASSENGER PLANES.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> THE TRADE DEFICIT IS RUNNING
AT ABOUT $69 BILLION A YEAR.
WE EXPECT THAT THE JAPANESE
PRESS WILL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP REGARDING
STEEL TARIFFS THAT IF, THAT ARE
TARGETED AT JAPAN.
TARIFFS ON STEEL AND ALUMINUM.
JAPAN BEING ONE OF OUR ONLY BIG
ALLIES THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THOSE TARIFFS.
>> Bret: WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT
HOW THE NEWS CYCLE IS DRINKING
FROM A FIRE HOSE.
A LOT OF IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS TWEETING.
TODAY NOT ONLY SHINZO ABE ON HIS
MIND BUT MAY BE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT HE TWEETED ABOUT
JAMES COMEY AND ALSO STORMY
DANIELS.
>> YEAH, CLEARLY JAMES COMEY HAS
BEEN ON HIS MIND, GIVING THOSE
INTERVIEWS.
YOUR INTERVIEW WITH COMEY IS
COMING UP.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING ABOUT
COMEY AND RUSSIA:
"SLIPPERY JAMES COMEY, THE WORST
FBI DIRECTOR IN HISTORY, WAS NOT
FIRED BECAUSE OF THE PHONY
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION WHERE, BY
THE WAY, THERE WAS NO COLLUSION
EXCEPT BY THE DEMS!"
STANDS IN CONTRAST TO AN
INTERVIEW HE GAVE WITH LESTER
HOLT IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT SAID
WHEN HE WENT TO FIRE JAMES COMEY
COMEY WAS TAKING ABOUT "THE
RUSSIA THING."
THE PRESIDENT ALSO TWEETING FOR
THE FIRST TIME TODAY ABOUT
STORMY DANIELS AFTER STORMY
DANIELS AND HER ATTORNEY MICHAEL
AVENATTI RELEASED THE SKETCH OF
A MYSTERY MAN WHO STORMY DANIELS
WERE TO SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TWEETED THIS MORNING: THE MAN
STORMY DANIELS ONCE DATED,
PROMPTING PRESIDENT TRUMP TO SAY
PROMPTING PRESIDENT TRUMP TO SA
SAY:
"A SKETCH YEARS LATER ABOUT
A NONEXISTENT MAN.
A TOTAL CON JOB, PLAYING
THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA FOR FOOLS
BUT THEY KNOW IT!"
TONIGHT MICHAEL AVENATTI
THREATENING TO FILE A DEFAMATION
SUIT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.